il vient tout juste de prendre ses
nouveaux quartiers
donc voilà londres qui a un avantage
avait norme c'est d'avoir une motion des
drapeaux européens vous avez trouvé le
riz entre bruxelles belfort et
strasbourg on est en train de le trouver
ce qui est certain c'est que je veux pas
être un député européen hors sol je veux
vraiment être ancré dans et horreur le
nord franche comté comme tous les
nouveaux députés
l'élue modem christophe grudler découvre
cette semaine le parlement de strasbourg
depuis leur élection fin mai les 751
députés européens travaillaient à
bruxelles
cette fois les choses sérieuses
commencent c'est beaucoup de joie parce
que ça va commencer pour de vrai on va
voter pour le président les
vice-présidents et on va pouvoir faire
un vrai travail de fond au profit des
habitants de l'union européenne
après une session inaugurale très formel
qui n'a duré qu'une vingtaine de minutes
nous retrouvons l'autre franc comtoise
du parlement anne sophie pelletier la
jurassienne ancien syndicaliste dans une
maison de retraite siège dans le groupe
de la gauche unitaire
c'est la continuité du combat des
opalines et c'est aussi venir défendre
en faisant les lois aussi en amendant
des textes pour que par exemple les
paquets ferroviaires ne passe pas vous
pour que dès privatisation de services
publics ne passe pas c'est pouvoir
essayer de vrai avec toute humilité pour
les gens juste les gens
défendre les services publics les
transports les droits fondamentaux
l'insoumis jurassienne a choisi ses
combats christophe kugler lui siègera
dans les commissions industrie énergie
affaires étrangères et défense
cinq ans de mandat attendent nos deux
élus comtois